I remember when you were born my lady
you were named for my aunt Lyanna who
said she was a great beauty I'm sure you
will be too
I doubt it my mother wasn't a great
beauty or any other kind of beauty she
was a great warrior though she died
fighting for your brother Rob I served
under your uncle at Castle black lady
Liana he was also a great warrior and
honorable man I was his steward in fact
I think we've had enough small talk
why are you here I've come with my
sister to ask for housewarmings
allegiance as far as I understand Juris
snow in lady Sandra is a Bolton who she
Lannister I've heard conflicting reports
I did what I had to do to survive milady
I'm a start I will always be Stark
if you say so what you have to
understand my lady is I understand that
I'm responsible for Bear Island and all
who live here so why should I sacrifice
one more moment life or someone else's
war your son was butchered as the red
wedding Lord monthly but you refused to
call you swore allegiance to House Stark
Lord giveth but in their hour of
greatest need you refused the cord and
you lured Kerwin your father was skinned
alive by Ramsay Bolton still you refused
the court but house Mormont remembers
the North remembers you expect me to put
a spear in my granddaughter's hand I
don't plan on knitting by the fire while
men fight for me I might be small rogue
lover and I might be a girl but I am
every bit as much a northerner as you
did you are my lady no need your
permission to defend the north
we'll begin training every man woman boy
and girl on bear island
there's no sense in man in the castles
anymore we make us stand here at once
your grace your grace but you're not are
you
you left Winterfell a king and came back
I'm not sure what you are now Oh Lord
nothing at all it's not important not
important we named you king in the north
[Applause]